this podcast is brought to you by on it
go to honor.com and look at the great
selection of supplements if you find
something you like
pressing code joey and get 10 off
delivered right to your house what's
happening you bad [__] it's
wednesday the 21st of [__]
september the joint is brought to you by
blue chew let me ask you something
remember when you were a teenager and
you get your dick rock hard in the blink
of a [__] eye
well blue chew is here and they want you
to have those youthful [__] hot ons
again
blue chew if you don't know is an online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and cialis but the
chewable talents
tablets and all at a fraction of a cost
take them any time
any place and be ready
for whatever when an opportunity arises
let me tell you something i love these
little bluetooth packages these little
pills they come in their own individual
packages and when you're ready to rock
whether you have an empty stomach or not
you could drop them you know what i'm
saying and it's simple you sign up at
bluetooth you consult with one of their
medical providers and once you're
approved
you'll receive your prescription within
days that's it the best part is it's all
done online no doctor's office no
conversations no drama made in the usa
has shipped in a discrete package even
the mailman won't [__] know
you can benefit from extra confidence
when it's time to sling dick with blue
chew
try blue chew for free when using promo
code joey j-o-e-y
just pay five dollars for shipping
that's bluetooth.com
code joey with your first month free
visit bluechew.com for more important
safety
information i want to thank blueshoe for
sponsoring the podcast
the joint is also brought to you by why
take the blue chew if your dick looks
like a [__] tornado hit it
the joint is brought to you by manscape
fall is coming don't let the cobwebs
surround around your [__] [__] and
your muffler manscaped is here to keep
your pumpkin patch clean and fresh let
me tell you something
i just trimmed my ball head here a day
in the shower [__] mcniffy geek i
trimmed around the pool of debt and now
i'm ready for [__] spring see fall
season man's cave performance package is
what you need
it's got it all they got the lawnmower
4.0
they got the weed whack the nose and ear
trimmer you got with safety skin
technology to protect your delicate
holes they're waterproof
so you can [__] shave in the shower
when it comes to the light that you
could even [__] shave your ball sack
in the dark okay
manscape even threw in two free gifts
in their package manscape boxes and the
shed travel bag take a look at the
shears 2.0 they cut right through my
[__] fungi toenail it includes steel
nail cutters tweezers and grooming
scissors
no more scratching your lady in bed with
those [__] hawk feet like i got get
20 percent off from free shipping with
code joey at manscape.com
that's 20 percent off and free shipping
with code joey at manscape.com
clears out the leaves
it's in your trunks time to shine
[__] and the joint is also brought
to you by my favorite daft king
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the nfl i'm talking
touchdowns big plays
[__] fumbles new customers can bet
five hours of the nfl team to win
and get 203 bets if they do
not hot enough for you
everyone can boost their winnings with
draftkings stepped up
same game paul a for every leg you had
you could boost your winnings up 100
100 [__] percent with bigger payouts
why bet football anywhere else [__] that
to make things even sweeter you can
throw down on the same game ballet
one per day all season long download the
draftking sports book app now and use
promo code joey to get 200 and three
bets if your team wins when you place a
five dollar bet on any football team
that's code joey only at draftkings
sportsbook an official sports betting
partner of the nfl minimum age and
eligibility restrictions apply
see show notes for details
draftkings download it and go win some
[__] money let's get this
podcast [__] started it's wednesday
morning
[Music]
welcome to uncle joy's joy
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday i think it's the 21st who
gives a frenchman's [__] it's a
beautiful [__] day to be alive
thank you for uh watching the last
couple podcasts and commenting it's
always great when lee comes on here it's
always great to see him
it's always great to give him edibles
it's always great to see him [__] up
and looking at you like his little eyes
now he looks like one of those things
you go to adam's you watch the addams
family and you [__] walk past
something and there's a picture and all
of a sudden the eyes move a little bit
when the guy walks by that's what lee's
eyes are like now like he's always like
looking around but it's always great to
see him it uh
you know when i see lee now i mean when
the podcast ended
i was just burnt out with everything
i was burnt out with la i was burnt out
with everything and i didn't know
when mine and lee's relationship would
end because i cancelled the podcast too
quickly and we just wanted to get out of
there you know i didn't know if his
feelings were hurt
or if my feelings were hurt i didn't
know really what to expect i i was
really looking
at the future going i don't know
if we're ever going to be friends again
i
i hate not being friends with somebody
so
it was just really weird when the
podcast ended we didn't do much like two
months he was in milwaukee [__]
detoxing
i was in the basement detoxing and
little by little we just started talking
and you know it was like
him and i were good friends and we
started everything we were doing
everything
but between the drugs and the [__]
podcast and the stand up it just you
know
it went somewhere else so when i see him
now and he comes down listen i was
really happy he came to do that show
because
it put me at ease like it just reminded
me of
the ice house on saturday nights
eight o'clock show we're out there at 10
no drama
you go up there we get high you see some
of your friends you hire your friends to
come
you pay them and that that's all but he
made it
i had no stress last week i had no
anxiety last week
my life has [__] changed i don't i
don't know how i got rid of anxiety or
talking through it or whatever but
it's gone you know i was talking on my
patreon podcast how
i started this journey last september
22nd so thursday
is a real year that i started thinking
about my future like what am i going to
do am i going to sit in this basement am
i going to feel like [__] am i going to
be confused
i didn't want this to
fail i hate failing everybody hates to
fail
can you imagine if we would have moved
here bought a home and then my wife
didn't like it and my daughter didn't
like it but after everything was settled
i had to find myself again and
my uh you know
why i work best and how i work best and
it wasn't
working constantly listen that ship sale
i'm just trying to sustain
have a good time and enjoy these years
i'm not [__] the spring chicken no
more you know what i'm saying i stay out
till two on a tuesday night it stays
with me till [__] friday okay
like my goal is to get home as soon as
possible because i know if i'm out till
three
whether it's just talking [__] and
smoking dope i'm gonna feel that [__] on
[__] friday i'm not like one of your
young [__] chickens no more but
all in all you know i'm happy that uh we
maintained our friendship friendships
are the most important thing you have
man you can't choose your family
but you could choose your [__]
friends and that's
that's very big and i tell people you
have to put up with [__] with friends
you know
the better you are as a friend the
better people
come to you like they just it's easier
you know
i went to jiu jitsu this morning and
it's so weird how i'm horrible at it
i keep showing up but the bonds i'm
building there with different guys now
like
when i came here i thought it was going
to be northberg in 1982. that's not what
i wanted at all
that's not what i was looking for at all
i was not looking for that
going down the show of my i have a
daughter i didn't want to get into all
that but
i still got to [__] sustain i still
got to move forward you know i found
what works for me
my goal now because i get bored at night
you know that's my biggest problem is
[__] night time i lose my mind at
night but i've lately with the girls
practice and the parents and
so i got a new goal now starting [__]
tomorrow i'm supposed to do one set
every week
like during the week just to get me out
of the [__] house and
i gotta go to jiu jitsu at night when
one night i [__] hate training at
night
you know that means you can't get high
all day that means you can't eat after
four
for me you know some people could do
what the [__] they want but if i go to
jiu-jitsu i can't get eye because not i
won't be able to breathe i can't breathe
when i [__] don't get high can you
imagine if i smoke 20 bongats all day
so these are the little things like for
the next year and this is what i tell
you people it all starts with little
[__] steps man
because when you start with big steps
you're gonna fall on your [__] face
and then you're gonna be more depressed
when you were and that's what i was
doing when i was younger
i would go for these big goals and these
big things and then when i wouldn't
reach him i'd quit that's not you're not
getting nowhere it's baby steps
today i'm gonna do this today i'm gonna
walk a mile today but you have a plan
a plan is sometimes unlike the most
important [__] thing you know
i've always been a good planner don't
ask me why i'm horrible at everything
else
but i could sit down and say how do i
attain this
and i could go step by step and i'll
scratch and put that step to number
three and number five you know you have
ten things to make your life better you
know so
i just wanted to start with that it's
always great to see lee and it just
reminds me about
the gift of friendship that we overlook
so much in our lives
like i said to you i rather you know
friends destroyed us
friends put this fake [__] view in
our lives that
we got to hang out with eight [__]
people or did you hang out with eight
people it sucks dick
there's always two of them that are
[__] [__] you gotta cover the
[__] slack listen man that's not what
it's about three four people
you exchange thoughts with them you tell
them your feelings whatever they tell
you from time to time i mean i can't
tell them that you know
i don't get hard on you know you know
what i'm saying like you just
you just you're just talking to people
and it's and that's what it's all about
just keeping it simple
be i have three guys that i grew up with
that i don't see him a lot
but i talked to them i wrapped them
every two days i could see that you know
they're my friends i don't need to see
them i just need to connect with them
speaking of connections
i [__] sit here all the time
anyway
when i go for drives and i always go at
the end of the [__] thought i go
i cannot believe that more people
haven't reached out to me from my past
like i really can't believe like
except for maybe two or three people
from colorado like boulder
and i don't even have a lot of people
left in boulder you know
uh i always figured that people would
hit me up from the aspen days like hey i
remember you holy [__] you know you were
funny back then when
nobody's ever [__] hit me
when i went to prison when i got out i'm
like all these i'm gonna have all these
prison buddies reach out to me including
the guy that threatened my life that
said for me to [__] uh
if i didn't get to stand up he was gonna
[__] kill me i thought he would pop
out and look for his 10 points you could
point me in the right direction nobody
ever popped out at me except one guy
that i had on early on at the church
his name was uh
alejandro reya rea mexican dude bad
[__] he was part of the cartel
before the cartel ever [__] knew they
were a cartel
and uh he was living in boulder and we
were
you know great friends in the halfway
house we had some great laughs
and then we both got out and i lost
contact with him and this [__]
hit me up
you know like
2013 maybe 14 i was blown away and he
said he was proud of me we talked
there's another guy from the halfway
house that i talk to from time to time
on facebook but i've never seen them but
the other day monday somebody reached
out to me
that guys i have not seen this
[__] from the 8th grade
8th grade
8th grade i have not seen this
[__]
i kind of forgot him i told some stories
about him on the [__] church and uh
it was just the [__] weirdest thing
he hit me up i just looked at an old
facebook you know you find messages
messenger or whatever
and i open up the messenger and it says
uh like the thing on the top of the
messenger dog i never even go to
messenger i must have clicked on the
wrong thing and that page came up and i
looked at a bunch of people joey how you
doing whatever
but there was this one mess and he goes
i don't know if you remember me
but when i looked at the thing it said
his name was rahul
and i go wow i grew up in a couple of
rauls you know rahul's a very big cuban
name you know raul
so i clicked onto it and it's like i
don't know if you remember me
i moved to north bergen in the [__]
uh in 1977 and
you lived across the street from me he
goes i heard on the podcast that you
stole my stereo i never thought it was
you oh my god
i [__] froze monday morning i'm like
what the [__]
so let me tell you how this thing
[__] went down
he lives in the bronx
his nephew went to see me sunday night
saturday night in new york city
his nephew comes home on saturday he's
at his mother's his sister's house who i
also know raul's sister
and the nephew go oh we went to see this
guy and raul's like who's this and they
started talking he's a cuban guy from
north bergen and raul goes wait a second
i used to live in north bergen let's
check them out and the guy goes as soon
as he put the video on that he looked at
me for like a minute he and all of a
sudden he just came back to him and he
had to reach out to me since we're not
friends and me and his son or his nephew
and our friends or whatever he reached
out to me on messenger but what a
coincidence that i never ever go on
messenger
and the day i click on messenger by
mistake because it was like a a thing on
facebook you know when i'm doing the
things in the morning you have to click
and post and link and whatever the [__]
i clicked the wrong [__] thing and
also it went to messenger and i opened
up the email
and uh he had his number on that i read
it and i i i must look at the email like
[__]
five times you know i'm like i can't
believe this guy i didn't know what
he knew i stole his stereo so i didn't
know that i should call him back
he left me the number
but guys i called him back and it was
like [__]
i i hadn't seen him in an hour
we went right back to north bergen he
asked me about louie hernandez
he asked me if i see you know because he
played basketball raul so he was a
basketball player
we must have talked for an hour on the
phone and uh he told me some [__] i
didn't know we're talking about puerto
rico nelson he reminded me that he threw
a snowball one time in puerto rico
nelson
because uh he thought that puerto rican
nelson had gotten a little
out of line with him you know so
it was good to talk to him about that he
confirmed what i thought about
puerto rican nelson was like a half a
pedophile you know what i'm saying like
he wasn't a full-time pedophile like he
was like
just a creepy dude but he didn't really
impose his will on us as much as you
would think from a pedophile you know so
but raul was saying that one day he said
something to him you know if you don't
eat broccoli you won't have a big [__]
or something he goes i don't know what
he [__] said to me but i whipped him
with a [__] snowball and just ran
away from him
raul was a kid to remind everybody when
we were in the seventh grade summer
like the summer or seventh grade we're
outside playing like stickball or
whatever the [__] we're playing
and what sort of moving truck comes in
right
and they're unloading [__] and the
family is all out there and they're
looking at this house and you know
and uh we watched them unload uh
that first batch of [__] you know like
they had like a little truck it was like
a little u-haul i don't even know if it
was a u-haul or whatever they unloaded
that one and then when they got ready to
go me and my friends who were little
[__] uh jackals
looked at each other and were like let's
go through the back window and see what
they got in there so like let's go you
know what at this time my mother was
alive i had no reason to break into a
house i had no reason to steal but it
was dead and my friends were there and
like let's do it i'm like okay let's
[__] do it and at that time it was a
joke
we would not
be any guys we were not heavy guys you
know we were robbed some motorcycles
once in a while from [__] sea
caulkers from the trains but
we weren't heavy guys so we went through
the back window
and uh we went in the house and one of
the guys stole like a picture
i saw he had a tremendous fissure stereo
now guys in 1979 if you had a [__]
fish or stereo you were the king of
[__] swing you understand me and this
is when they had like all components at
one which i'd never do again the eight
track the cassette and the [__] album
and
so i saw the fish's stereo and i go you
know what i'm taking this [__] i
didn't know that they had a [__] 12
year old son that was my age so i took
the stereo i [__]
took it to my room we robbed a couple
things a stereo a lamp a bike you know
just stupid [__] that kids do
please for you people are watching this
to woke uh liberals do not hold it
against me i know that you're like you
robbed somebody in 1978 yeah it was 1978
44 years ago get over it [__]
nobody even talks about it anymore you
can't even press charges so don't judge
who gives a [__]
so we took the [__] stereo and a
couple other things and
about a week later you know we start
school and the kids [__] great his
name was rahul puerto rican kid he
smoked dope like us he played hoops so
we became friends you know i like the
kid nolson one days i'm like let's go
back to my house and watch movies or
whatever the [__] we're gonna do and
also when i walk in my house i go [__]
i can't [__] ask this kid
to listen to music because he's going to
see that i stole the stereo
this kid lived right across the street
from me not three houses down not eight
houses down
right across you know when you come out
of your front door in that house right
right across the [__] street from me
so i'd have to see him every day i
didn't even think about that [__] so
when he's like oh we gonna listen to
music i'm like nah nah nah nah my stereo
is kind of [__] up let's go to the
basement the basement i had like
punching bags and karate [__]
so the whole time
he i think he lived in north bergen
maybe till the end of the eighth grade
and
the whole time he came to my house every
day i couldn't take him to my bedroom
because his [__] stereo
was in my goddamn bedroom i couldn't
even walk up the block with an album
because he would ask me let's look at it
and let's listen to it so i had to call
on charles court jump the fence go
through my backyard leave the album in
the back door and then walk up my block
go to the garage say hello to him close
the garage and bring the album to the
backyard so he wouldn't see me [__]
bring albums home it was horrible it was
a horrible thing i did and trust me if
at the time if i could say to him raul
take the stereo i would i just didn't
have the balls you know i didn't have
the balls
but what happened with raul was raul's
father borrowed money from my stepfather
and my stepfather was a loan shark and
my stepfather was rigging him
and he couldn't play the victim one day
they just split in the middle of night
and [__] and
my step-father was pissed but i'm like
hey i got the stereo
you got beat but i got something you
know what i'm saying but
he was telling me about my stepfather he
said that he still remembered my mother
he in fact he asked me how my mother was
and i was like she died in 19 [__] 79
he's like
wow and he started talking with my
mother
he would come over and eat can you ima
how do you have a kid over your house
and eat and you can't take him to your
bedroom because you stole his [__]
stereo i mean
what the [__] did i get myself into you
know
he's uh a plumber he owns his own
plumbing company
we're gonna hook up uh next time i'm in
the city he's gonna come to the show and
we're gonna chit chat a little more
i apologized about the stereo you know
uh he didn't really know about the
stereo i told him
and uh
it's [__] crazy how fast 44 [__]
years and the kids still remember me and
trust truthfully i remembered him still
it's not like i [__] blacked him out
but
it's great talking to people from the
past sometimes he was just reminding me
of like the stupid [__] we did
he reminded me when he stole the van
with all the [__] t-shirts in them
and the shirt press and we took it to
the city guys we were you know i think
my daughter to get baseball cards at
this place like once every two weeks we
go in there we buy five packs
i look around but it's really a comic
book place and it's [__] cool as [__]
and raul lived on our block when all of
us used to rob a comic book guy
his name was anthony something
me raul ray canella i mean reagan's been
on the church couple times he used to
work for the sci-fi network
we used to [__] dean lapreet another
good friend of mine we used to smoke now
we didn't smoke dope then we had a band
i was in a band
i played bass no i [__] sang
i sang
my buddy john played the bass
doug jimenez played the guitar
and frank canela played the drums but
then my voice started cracking
so i didn't sound like michael jackson
anymore so my singing days were [__]
over
but we [__] uh
you know
we just
he reminded me of so many [__] things
we talked about a van one night we were
playing basketball and we walked back
home and we all of us would always like
you know we drink water out of a [__]
hose and [__]
and there was a hose right on liberty
avenue and we used to just
grab the guy's [__] hose and while
we're drinking the hose we're looking at
this van and we noticed that the van
don't [__] belong that
well like this we've never seen this van
before
so at night every night after basketball
it was one of those police phones 9-1-1
phones close to the school the the for
how we started tonight every night was
ripping the phone out of the box just
ripping it and leaving the box open and
cops would be everywhere they would even
set us up and we'd still get away from
them it was tremendous
after we'd robbed the box from that then
we'd go on and you know
we'd like lucy's [__] you know lucy
snowbush had goldfish in front of a
house in a bowl and we put lighter fluid
on it and light it on fire come on guys
come on i thought you knew about this
[__] well you know this is what you do
when you're young in north berg and
we're [__] crazy kids
so one night we're just standing and
there's this van and we look in the van
and we're like wow they got boxes of
t-shirts
and guys don't remember this you guys
are too young to remember this in the
70s you'd go into a store and there
would be designs on the wall
like led zeppelin pink floyd yeah like
stupid [__] follow me i'm with stupid
all that stuff and they would put the
shirt down and they'd have like an iron
like this and they sting the thing you
press the button after two minutes you
picked it up and you sure had a sticker
on it we looked in the van and the
[__] guy had one of those presses in
we took the bro one of the guys
we were [__] we're like
should we just bust into the van and
take it out and we're like no no no no
so my friend said i could drive
so we drove the [__] and he got in the
car i was petrified i've never jumped in
a stone car
stolen cars aren't my thing you got
nowhere to go when the cops pull you
over i'm in the car you can't talk
yourself out of it i'm saying you're in
the car so where the [__] are you going
so
we uh
he drives the [__] thing around there
was a girl lona mertens
and she lived in this apartment building
and they had like parking garages back
then we pulled the van in there
and we [__] started
taking everything boxes of t-shirts
presses all the designs mickey mouse
spider-man
he had like
the fantastic four we were comic book
nerds so we're like oh [__]
and this is way before comic con they
had these little conventions in the city
you know comic book things and they
would sell those shirts and i'll never
forget we took a [__] bus
with boxes of shirts
each of us had a box on the bus the bus
driver was like what the [__] where are
you going they finally the bus driver
finally said get off the bus put it on
the side it was six of us with big boxes
and we brought a press
we brought the [__] press to the city
our plan was to go into the convention
and [__] sell t-shirts we didn't give
a [__] we didn't know about boots we
didn't know about boot fees we knew
nothing we just thought you showed up
like the english town [__] uh flea
market and you sold [__] we go upstairs
and they're like nah you can't [__]
do this like we don't give a [__] we
just want to sell these we'll sell them
cheap the guy finally goes [__] it i'll
buy this shirt from you
we sold all the shirts we sold the press
we sold the stickers to the guy we
started a [__] the guy started a
business right there on a saturday
morning we took our money we got back on
that [__] bus
went to north bergen bought albums you
know chinese food [__]
darts that you know what kids [__] with
stupid [__] kids throw out but we
used to and in those days we would get
home at three o'clock
about 3 10 i'd make a [__] grilled
cheese sandwich or something
and i'd run over to [__] uh ray
canella's house dean lapree would come
over raul would come over it'd be like
six of us and there was this guy on 43rd
street his name was anthony something
sweetheart of a guy lived with his
parents half a momo but what are you
gonna do we all can't be [__] brain
surgeons
in his front porch he had a comic book
store
so think about my front porch sealing it
off and he had a comic book store in
there so before you walked in the house
you got to walk through the comic book
store
anthony de palma anthony rosetti
something like that
we would go up there every [__] day
and bust his ball how much for superman
won how much for superman 2.
how much for superman 3. can you give it
to me for 15 and the whole time we're
busting his balls two of us are stealing
comic books from like [__] we're
walking out there with comic books heavy
we stole
the we stole the whole fantastic four
from him
the whole [__] i love the fantastic
four then because they had silver surfer
in fact i'm thinking of [__]
collecting silver surfers against silver
surfer
i love all that [__] i love that [__] as
a kid i never had superman i
but i was a fantastic four guy
silver surfer guy
and that was somebody else i don't know
i never know about the black panther and
all these comic heroes that they're
coming up with [__] now they're so
[__] many now i know the rock is
black angus i don't even know what the
[__] i don't even know what the [__]
he's doing he's hawaii and he wants to
be black angus now
who the [__] knows anymore but man
it was just it was just really good
talking to him and uh
you know guys i had a great childhood
before my parents died before my mother
died guys
you know it was like i had a couple of
bumps when i first moved to jersey i got
beat up and all that but then after a
while i was just
i was moving and that's what we spoke
about he was like you know when i left
you were really like you know
we were [__] we were playing
basketball we were
we went to karate together
we were just a bunch of kids that had
fun you know i look at my daughter
and i look at these kids today and down
here we can never do this because the
houses are too separated there's really
no streets to walk around on there's
really not much for the kids you know
but
guys my like my daughter comes home now
at three o'clock and
you know she gets in like 3 15 and i got
to be strictly honest with you
we do nothing
these kids do nothing
i gotta every day i gotta [__] tell
them mercy go knock on
you know frank's door uh go knock on you
know the russian's door go knock on the
kid across the streets door you know and
everybody has different events
but it's not like you know on the block
over where jimmy florentine lives yeah
they got jimmy oh they got little luca
over there and they got a couple kids
over there and there's like three of
them that come out every day but they
really got like 10 kids on that block
and sometimes six of them come out and
when the hindus come out you got 10
[__] kids out there running it's
tremendous you know but these kids today
don't don't do it i've told my wife i go
we got to figure something out i don't
want to put an after-school program that
[__] sucks you know i wanted to run
these streets here i wanted to [__]
uh you know walk around a little bit but
like i said there's nowhere to [__]
go and that's why i always if it wasn't
for these felonies guys
because listen you can't i contacted an
attorney
for years all these [__] were
like oh joey you could get rid of all
those felonies until i [__] contacted
an appointment a [__] attorney and
went in for a consultation it cost me
500 bucks for him to tell me
that everybody has to be in place for
your felonies to get aligned what that
means is
that d.a
has to [__] go for it
the attorney the victims the whole
[__] thing but you know i know vela
will he won't have any objections on me
erasing the film but the d.a that
[__] va that prosecuted me he left
right after he prosecuted me he [__]
went to the feds to uh prosecute
environmental [__] people they're not
even gonna remember this [__] case
like they're not gonna remember all the
they'll read it they'll come back to
them but they're not going to remember
all this [__] like what happened exactly
so
i really wanted to get my things
expunged for one reason
just so i could work with kids i could
[__]
you know coach a little league team or
coach a [__] midi basketball team i
don't wanna i i know i know i'm a felon
but there were i didn't have a drug
felony i didn't have a sex felony or a
kid felony or an assault it was
basically a [__] second degree
burglary felony if they look at their
initial charges yeah they might go
but it wasn't as easy and they wanted
like [__] the attorney told me
it was like 50 grand i don't have
[__] 50 grand to expunge my [__]
my past who gives a [__] if you want to
look at it look at it if you're not
judging me but but it doesn't matter i
thought that i could [__] expunge
this [__] but
[Music]
so that's my [__] situation and i
gotta [__] live with it
but it's always great when somebody from
that capacity
it [__] up me for two days i was i
couldn't wait to do this podcast because
there was nobody really i could tell
about how i felt after i got off the
phone with him it was like
brought the fresh air hit my lungs it
was a different perspective you know
he was talking about my mother and he
goes my mother was very kind to him that
my mother even if i wasn't home she
offered him food
he goes how much food you guys have in
your house
because your mom would always offer me
[__] food constantly like steaks and
my friends love my mom because at my
house there was no tuna sandwiches jack
there was no fishing sticks
there was no [__] uh macaroni and
cheese my mother wouldn't go for that
[__] at all
in my house if you came in there to eat
it was a steak
apollo mia not a t-bone those the skinny
ones that they bang with the [__]
hammer and it looks like a [__] side
of a cow
my mother would make you one of those
with black beans rice onions and some
fried bananas
i still remember us [__] sleeping
over ferny me
a villa a bunch of us sleeping over and
getting up and my mom made [__]
that disgusting cuban dish i told you
about whey wok ohio that's when you get
white rice a [__] steak
and you crack two eggs over it and you
crack the yolks so the eggs go over the
steak and the rice disgusting
but [__] effective if you're looking
for a hard on let me tell you something
if you're not using blue chew it's that
[__] right there jack your dick will get
[__] hard two eggs
the yolk over a piece of [__] meat
that stimulates [__] [__] right there
in the [__] nut sack and then that
rice and that [__] malokia [__]
yolk juice [__]
i still remember them [__] like
making noises while they ate like i
still remember like me being embarrassed
because i was always embarrassed when
non-white kids right at my house because
my mom wouldn't give him white food
but then after three minutes the kids
would go [__] that [__] i'm coming over
here all the time i'm sick of macaroni
and cheese i'm sick of eating potatoes
your mom never cooks potatoes [__] no
it's [__] steak and they would come
over
she would buy the [__] we would go to
a meat packing district
once a week and my mom would buy boxes
of t-bone steaks
the [__] thick ones nice medium size
with two eggs in the morning god damn
too bad now i can't
do that much [__] meat you know
he also told me that
he liked my stepfather even though my
stepfather was a prick i think i'm on my
stepfather
[__] all the time but i also think
about my stepfather in a weird way
because it depends on the day with me
whether i love my stepfather or i don't
i love my stepfather because
i learned something big from him you
know his main thing was
that was his [__] main words all the
time that means don't be a shitty and
what that means in cuban it's not that
you eat [__]
he always wanted me to be on top of my
game those old revolutionary cubans like
i didn't understand one
when he was in my life i i started
understanding one
when he was out of my life and i was a
[__]
and for me to get back i had to use
some of the things juan was very you
know
one was one of those guys like you know
what i didn't eat dinner tonight [__]
you you should have been here at six
that's it there's no dinner like go [__]
yourself
and you feel bad about it but you're
like you know what that's that's life
that's [__] life sometimes
dinner is a six you didn't eat you
didn't come at six you came at seven i
cleaned up the kitchen go [__] yourself
now i ain't giving you money to eat
juan was one of those dudes that made
you work a little harder but he was
always right
i was too young at the time to
appreciate it because you know you want
to be a [__] gangster you want to be
a kid
that dude was always right you know
those guys that
are always right you get [__] pissed
off they always [__] prove you're
right you're like god damn it
[__] he was one of those guys
so as i got older like as i got into my
40s when i got off the drugs and [__] i
started feeling his presence more in my
life
and he didn't have that much of a
presence in my life
but
some of the [__]
his way of looking at things is
it's life there was no second chances
you know
you were supposed to be that nine and
you weren't there and they [__]
didn't hire you go [__] yourself
your excuse is not gonna work your
excuse is [__] worthless to me
he didn't like excuses and it's the
truth
you ever tell something to somebody and
they hit you with a [__] half-assed
excuse and you're like what the [__]
what the [__] just say that i [__] up
that's it move on i won't be [__]
pissed i don't give a [__] we all [__]
up
but it was great just like
thinking about my stepfather how much i
hated him growing up
but how much today
i see a little bit of me and him like
that's
you know i get up early every morning i
do things he was the type of dude that
this guy had money and he would [__]
confuse people he always had an old car
and he always wore jeans and [__]
jean jackets he wore the same clothes
every day to [__] with you
he outsmarted people he always played
like a dopey guy
you know like when i see all the whole
videos of vinnie the chinchigante like
people like yeah he always played like
he was [__] crazy and [__] all those
old criminals did that [__] they always
had a problem they're hearing you know
they always got [__] an excuse i miss
one today i think about him he died in
2006 and
he didn't give me my mother's money and
i was always angry at him but at the end
i didn't need my mother's money
he kept it and listened to this how bad
his life was
when he died he had a box full of cash
maybe two million dollars that he
couldn't put in the bank or anything
because he was a bookmaker
when he died he gave that money to his
wife at the time
within a month
she got [__] a cancer [__] notice
and she died within six months
she gave the money to her brother
guess what happened to him he died a
year later
so the money ended up going back to my
stepfather's
daughter in tampa
and god knows what she's doing with that
[__] money that money was bad luck
jack
and for years i wanted that money and at
the end i'm happy i didn't [__] i
didn't even have it go through my
[__] house because god knows how bad
that [__] money was
but that's it and that's that guys
that's what i wanted to talk about a
friend of yours calling you from the
past and just
opening up your brain like i was
listening it took me and especially how
it went down
from his nephew going to the show
saturday night and then him going home
and
he
goes i talked to my nephew all the time
i didn't even know he was into [__]
comedy i didn't know when he became into
comedy or whatever
that's what he asked me i told him i had
done some time
uh
you know he never got arrested
he says he uh got caught up on the
cocaine bug a little bit
but then he went to a rehab and uh
somebody he was doing coke with died and
he stopped doing coke
we're both 59 we're both gonna be 60
next year so uh
i talked to him and i said i'd like him
to come over one day maybe do sit down
on the podcast one day
listen to bronx he lives in the bronx so
uh
he says he wants to come over and do the
podcast
and explain to you guys a little bit you
know his year in north bergen like he
had
you know he talked to me about karma and
balzano he goes i was there today
[__] carmine beat up the teacher and
he goes i was there today
we were talking about when he beat up
this dude mr clemons oh my god
we were [__] dying on the phone
the clemens family was a great little
family i lived two houses next to me so
next to me was cathy ortiz they were
jehovah witnesses and then the bike
thief
thief lived upstairs valentine pharah
and then next to him were the clemens
says the clemenses were a tremendous
family
great family the only problem was they
all had fleas
they all had uh they all had what's that
[__] in your hair lice
so they all had to get crew cuts but it
didn't that's it once you have lice in
north bergen you have lice forever they
will torture you you might as well keep
the lice
because like i always said nancy was a
beautiful girl but nobody ever thought i
eaten a [__] because she had lice trust
me what i'm telling you this [__]
so
so one day [__]
we're outside doing whatever the [__] we
did you know in the summers
in north bergen then everybody would go
out to the front of the house it was the
clemens the [__] uh the latino that
[__] racist italian guy across from
the clemens
uh the artists didn't go out there with
jehovah witnesses they don't mingle with
nobody it was us my mother wouldn't go
out of the house but like tristano would
go out and there was a lady up the
corner and she was an italian lady who
would send the pornos to we were kids
she would go out there sweep the front
i don't know what the [__] was going on
this is a great [__] we're out there
just playing and all of a sudden there
was an argument
i don't know over like stupid [__] just
two kids
then the father came on he goes what's
this [__] young and screaming about
but he goes listen man that's my [__]
toy i don't know
well i don't know the next thing i hear
is like a [__] push and a kid goes
down
and mr clemons is standing over and he
and i look to see who's on the floor
and it's the last guy i want to see on
the floor it's anthony balzano
i'm like god damn it so i run over mr
clemons what the [__] and he goes [__]
this little guy
and [__] his father i'm sick and tired
and i'm [__] uh bothering people and
thinking they could bully people i go
he's not bullying your son in fact your
son is older than he is
i think that's his ball or whatever i
don't know
but anthony [__] didn't like it and
he went to altino's house and called his
father
and i didn't see him call the father i
just i was too busy talking to mr
clemens and what had happened and all of
a sudden guys i see anthony come back
and he whispers in my ear keep talking
to him i'm like
i'm like what i don't know what he meant
by that
and next thing you know i see a solo cop
car come up the block
no lights no [__]
it was a detective and it was carmine
and he gets out of the car and right
away i knew what time it was but he had
already thrown out two beatings in the
last two years i didn't think he was
going to beat up mr [__] clemens
i think we ended up calling miss because
they used to say clamito right they used
to the spanish kids called them clamito
now at that time in north park and there
was maybe 10 spanish kids but this the
white kids liked the way they said bioho
they would always go how do you say lice
in spanish
so the spanish kids taught the white
kids how to say lice in spanish was
which is
right so we would say clamito tiene
piojo every all the white kids would say
that in spanish to him and he would lose
his [__] mind so i don't know what
the [__] happened people were saying
clamito tenepio
carmine comes up to mr clemens and i
don't think he liked mr clemons at all
mr clemons was a nice guy but he was the
leader of that crew cut you know that
crew cut that comes out straight with
the [__] it looks like a an anvil on
your [__] head he had one of those
[__] things
so [__] uh
one thing leads to another
and within two minutes carmine smacks
this [__] with the walkie-talkie
batteries all over the floor
he goes down he's blue he's got to cut
over his eye he's bleeding he goes down
the guy goes down and holds his face
carmine takes his hands
and puts the handcuffs on
and proceeds just to start smacking them
right
but after the third punch it was the guy
was out
blood was everywhere kids are going
crazy head on man him he's got fleas
it was not good right hit him punch him
the kids the kids were outside crying
the mother was holding the one girl they
had like seven kids carmine's punching
them and [__] the guy's yelling police
brutality police brutality call the cops
listen at that point
everybody who was up got up and started
sweeping
their front balcony i still remember
when carmine got up he took the
handcuffs off the [__] guy
and mr clemens kept saying you all saw
that and nobody called the police what
are you what kind of citizens are you
and nobody said raised a [__] boot
everybody just kept sweeping we don't
know dick we don't know nothing we don't
know dick we don't know nothing
everybody kept sweeping sweeping
sweeping
he got up and he [__] we were kind of
like laughing but after i saw the kids i
kind of felt a little bad
but i still love that climber and beat
them up when you're [__] 12 anybody
gets beat up you're [__] it's a good
day in your neighborhood
so [__]
he pushed anthony but anthony kind of
went after him you know anthony always
knew his father would show up
so if i know my father's gonna show up
and there's no i'm gonna pick a fight
with you two every [__] day
but we all saw that and raul was like
i go did you ever go to con my insides
he goes no
he goes and after i saw him throw the
beat and i missed the tutorial because
in the eighth grade he threw a beating
on a [__] gym teacher too at the
school so he was like i never went over
a lot of kids weren't a lot over his
house me i loved going over there when i
got to that
they were the first house i ever went to
that they had a slicer
a [__] cold cut slicer and they would
put ham on the [__] slicer and you
could cut the [__] ham and they would
make white rice and they would heat up
cream of turkey soup or cream of chicken
soup and you would take the [__] ham
put on the rice and then pour the cream
of turkey soup it's white trash food but
guess what when you're 12 you eat that
[__] right the [__] up you get me
anyway without further ado
that's it and that's that it was a
simple podcast today i didn't want to
get in too deep next week we got our
guests coming back i had three guests in
a row i know you guys like the solo ones
but on this particular wednesday i ain't
got dick to say you follow me i went to
the doctor yesterday did a biopsy on my
[__] chin i'll get the results
they're gonna have to slice it so uh in
the next couple weeks we might have to
[__] not do a podcast because they
want to stitch it yeah this is not good
guys
this is not good this is a [__]
ingrown hair that is probably like three
inches
long in there that's one of those white
hairs dude i get them all the time they
suck they [__] suck i manscape them i
put everything you know i manscape the
nut sack then you go up double up on the
[__] beard but anyway i love you
[__] with all my heart uh
football
has been great this year guys i've made
money the first two weekends and i'm no
[__] swami from salami when i say i
made money if i made 50 bucks both
weekends i had the jets and the giants
last weekend at buffalo on monday night
i didn't bet the minnesota viking game i
didn't know
i did have [__] green bay on sunday
the only loser i had was [__]
indianapolis they lost my [__] 30
those [__] duckers
but man draftkings has been great thank
god their sponsor this week that's it
guys have a great week have some fun and
we'll be back monday
tip top magoo ready for you
[__]
all right i want to thank you guys for
listening this week i'm sorry about
today it was one of those weird podcasts
but [__] it i'll come back stronger on
monday
the joint is brought to you by blue chew
listen when you were young
if the wind blew your dick got hard
blue chew is here to make that [__]
dream come true again
you're asking me joy what's blue chew is
an online service that delivers the same
active ingredients
as viagra and cialis but in chewable
tablets take them any time and be ready
for whenever the opportunity arises
i love blue chew one pill empty stomach
your dick is harder than hell listen
i'm old you follow me and i need some
help but even if you don't need help you
could use that extra dick because you
wanted to call back
all right sign up at bluetooth.com
consult one of their medical providers
and once you're approved you'll receive
your prescription within days the best
part is it's all done online no doctor's
office no awkward conversations no brow
beating if you could benefit from extra
confidence when it's time to sling nick
blue chew can help
try blue chew for free when using promo
code joey just pay five dollars for
shipping and i'm going to hook you up
with some bluetooth so go to
bluetooth.com enter codejoey and get
your first month for [__] free visit
bluetooth.com for more safety
information and i want to thank bluechu
for sponsoring the church
the joint the joint is also brought to
you by manscape if your dick looks like
the [__]
tornado results after [__] what
happened to puerto rico look at it if
it's got swamp all over your [__] you
need some help [__] and manscaped
is here to help you manscape it's a
performance package 4.0 has it all okay
my endorsement on this is it's
tremendous i've been with manscape for
five years i've been telling you about
manscape for five [__] years and it
works tremendous it's a 4.0 load more
and it's a body trim i don't care where
you use it i even use it on my toe head
weed whackers for your nose and ear and
it has skin safe technology to protect
your delicate holes i don't want you to
cut yourself and number two it's
waterproof so you can even shave your
nutsack in the shower manscape is even
gonna throw in two gifts to that package
the boxes and the shed travel bag
take a look at the shears 2.0
their luxury nail crewman kit it's
[__] tremendous they can cut right
through my bunga toenail tweezers
grooming scissors no more scratching
your lady in bed with those [__]
hooks
get 20 percent off from free shipping
with code joey at
manscape.com again that's 20 percent off
from free shipping with code joey at
manscape.com manscape will clear out the
leaves
and [__] make your dick look like a
[__] statue of love
the joint is also brought to you by
draftking sportsbook listen i'm talking
touchdowns big plays and even bigger
[__] wins this weekend new
customers can bet five hours on any
football team to win and get 203 bets
when it comes true for you if that's not
hot enough everybody can boost their
winnings with draftkings stepped up same
game paul a's for every leg you add you
can boost your winnings up to a hundred
percent with bigger payouts
than ever why bet football anywhere else
to make things even sweeter you can
throw down same game parlays once
per day all season long but it starts
with you if you're looking to win some
money and be on the best [__]
sports betting site there is go with
draftking sportsbook and use promo code
joey to get 203 bets if your team wins
you place five hours on a football team
listen that's code joey only at
draftkings sportsbook an official sports
betting partner of the nfl
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details
draftkings download it and go win some
[__] money and make some good money
with prophets i want to thank draftkings
i want to thank
better help i want to thank
manscape i want to thank bluechu
draftkings but most importantly i want
to thank you guys for a great [__]
week thank you for supporting me thank
you for having my back and i'll see you
[__] next monday
tip top magoo stay black
[Music]
you